oh boy christmas came early today what's  up everyone  Tim Harvey jr. here at the Levi's store  in Times Square here's surprise a huge  fan does not know that I'm here to pick  out the new jeans from Goa his fresh J's  let's get this thing going very very  important on how your denim lays on top  of your sneakers we've got some J's in  the back and we picked out the styles  for you let's go try all mine I'm  talking about do me I feel you I feel  you guys show the tongue man you guys  throw on a J's on the 4th let's see what  else we got ok I see with the 500 ones  on camel at the Air Jordan 9 boots on I  feel like for the last and final fish go  ahead check them out christmas came  early today  I see how you doing good right no you  guys making you creep some to net you  know want to send you off with all this  gear you press now yes no doubt about  that no doubt appreciate down  [Music]